the graph of function f is given below
it has a vertical tangent at the point
three comma zero so three comma zero has
a vertical tangent let me draw that
so it has a vertical tangent right over
there
and a horizontal tangent at the point
zero comma negative three zero comma
negative three so it has a
horizontal tangent
right over there
and also has a horizontal tangent at six
comma three so six comma three let me
draw
the horizontal tangent
just like that
select all the x values for which f is
not differentiable select all that apply
so f prime
f prime like i'll write into a shorthand
so we say no f prime
under it's going to happen under three
conditions the first condition you could
say well we have a vertical tangent
vertical tangent why is a vertical
tangent to place where it's hard to
define our derivative well remember our
derivative is we're really trying to
find a rate of change of y with respect
to x but when you when you have a
vertical tangent you change your x a
very small amount you have an infinite
change in y either in the positive or
the negative direction so that's one
situation where you have no at no
derivative and they tell us where we
have a vertical tangent here where x is
equal to three so we have
no
we f is not differentiable at x equals 3
because of the vertical tangent you
might say what about horizontal tangents
no horizontal tangents are completely
fine horizontal tangents are places
where the derivative is equal to 0. so f
prime of 6 is equal to 0. f prime of
zero is equal to zero
what are other scenarios well another
scenario where you're not going to have
a defined derivative is where the graph
is not continuous
not
continuous and we see right over here at
x equals negative three our graph is not
continuous so x equals negative three
it's not continuous and those are the
only places where f is not
differentiable that they've that they're
giving us options on we don't know what
what the graph is doing to the left or
the right these are i guess would be
interesting cases but they haven't they
haven't given us those choices here and
we already said at x equals zero the
derivative is zero it's defined it's
differentiable there and at x equals 6
the derivative is 0. we have a flat flat
tangent so once again it's defined there
as well let's do another one of these
oh and actually i didn't include i think
that this takes care of this problem but
there's a third scenario in which we
have
i'll call it a sharp turn
a sharp
turn and this isn't the most mathy
definition right over here but it's easy
to recognize a sharp turn is something
like that or
like
or like well that doesn't look too sharp
or like
this and the reason why i think where
you have these sharp bends or sharp
turns as opposed to something that looks
more smooth like that the reason why
we're not differentiable there is as we
approach the this point
as we approach this point from either
side we have different slopes notice our
slope is positive right over here where
as x increases where y is increasing
well our slope is negative here so as
you try to find the limit of of our
slope as we approach this point it's not
going to exist because it's different on
the left hand side and the right hand
side so that's why the sharp turns i
don't see any sharp turns here so it
doesn't apply to this example
let's do one more examples and actually
this one does have some sharp terms so
this could be this could be interesting
the graph of function f is given to the
left right here it has a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative 3. we see
that and horizontal asymptotes at y
equals zero yep this this end of the
curve as x approaches negative infinity
it looks like y is approaching zero and
has another horizontal asymptote at y
equals four as x approaches infinity it
looks like our graph is trending down to
y is equal to four
select the x values for which f is not
differentiable
so first of all we could think about
vertical
tangents
don't
doesn't seem to have any vertical
tangents then we could think about where
we are not continuous well we're
definitely not continuous where we have
this vertical asymptote right over here
so we're not continuous at x equals
negative 3. we're also not continuous
that x is equal to 1.
and then the last situation where we are
not going to be differentiable is where
we have a sharp turn or you could kind
of view it as a sharp point on our graph
and i see a sharp point right over there
notice as we approach from the left hand
side the slope looks like a looks like a
constant i don't know is this like a
positive 3 halves well right as we go to
the right side of that it looks like our
slope turns negative and so if you were
to try to find the limit of the slope as
we approach from either side which
essentially what you're trying to do
when you try to find the derivative well
it's not going to be defined because
it's different on either side so we also
the f is also not differentiable at this
at the x value that gives us that little
sharp that sharp point right over there
and if you were to graph the derivative
which we will do in future videos you
will see that the derivative is not
continuous at that point so let me
mark that off and then we could check x
equals zero x equals zero is completely
cool we're at a point that uh
our tangent line is definitely not
vertical we're definitely continuous
there we definitely do not have a sharp
point or edge so we're completely cool
at x equals zero